and he's done a fantastic job for the
people of California and also the people
of California have done a fantastic job
when you look at the at the bump you
take a look at the bump and how they're
doing out there so I congratulate
everybody out there but I thought I'd
have Kevin say a few words so Kevin
please
well Thank You mr. president and I would
like to thank you I'm based of
California governor Newsom says the work
that you're doing together as been
working very closely has been effective
in California as well vice president the
president you know today mr. president I
want to thank you especially for the
work this secretary minuchin has done
especially for small businesses just
today alone
I saw Bank of America had more than
10,000 loans in two hours but for
anybody who's in small business on first
football business when I was 20 years
old you don't have income coming in
right now you get a loan but for your
rent paying your employees and paying
your utilities is a grant that's part of
the cares Act and I think you're gonna
find that a lot of small business is
going to hire people back keep them
afloat through the next two months and
get this economy moving again as we get
through this virus so I just want to
thank you for all thank you I'll talk to
you later all right
okay thank you very much everybody and I
want to start by saying that our hearts
go out to the people of New York as they
bear the brunt of the corona virus
pandemic in America that seems to be the
hot spot right now but you have some
others as you know that a very very bad
very bad Louisiana is getting hit very
hard parts of Michigan and getting hit
very very hard
New Jersey is is surprisingly it's much
greater than anybody would have thought
they're doing a really good job
governor's doing a really good job out
there New York's first responders EMTs
doctors nurses are showing incredible
courage under pressure they're the best
in the world we will take every action
and we'll spare no resource financial
medical scientific we will not spare
anything we'll get it back into shape
the empire state the governor's doing an
excellent job they're all working very
hard together at the request of the
governor as you know the Javits Center
we have 2,500 beds and we're going to
allow that to be a system where this
horrible disease can be looked after the
patients can be looked after that was
going to be for regular medical problems
such as accidents and you know it's very
interesting the governor's tell me we
don't have too many accidents and very
few people driving so we're going to put
that facility into play which is a big
facility the ship will be staying the
way it is but we're putting that
facility into play to help them and
today also the CDC is announcing
additional steps Americans can take to
defend against the transmission of the
virus from recent studies we know that
the transmission from individuals
without symptoms is playing a more
significant role in the spread of the
virus than previously understood so you
don't seem to have symptoms and it still
gets transferred in light of these
studies the CDC is advising the years
of non-medical cloth face covering as an
additional voluntary public health
specialist so it's voluntary you'd have
to do it there they suggested for a
period of time but this is voluntary I
don't think I'm gonna be doing it but
you have a lot of ways you can look at
it as follows the CDC is recommending
that Americans were a basic cloth or
fabric mask they can be either purchased
online or simply made at home probably
material that you'd have at home
these face coverings can be easily
washed or reuse I want to emphasize that
the CDC is not recommending the use of
medical grade or surgical grade masks
and we want that to be used for our
great medical people that are working so
hard and doing some job medical
protective gear must be reserved for the
frontline healthcare workers who are
performing those vital services the new
mask guidelines also do not replace
CDC's guidance on social distancing
including staying in your home when
possible standing at least 6 feet apart
for a period of time again we're going
to all come back together here we're
going to all come back together and
practicing hand hygiene which we should
do anyway
a lot of things I think are going to
spill over shaking hands maybe we'll
stay with our country for a long time
beyond this one of the one of our great
doctors was telling me that as you know
we have flus every year and the number
of people killed by the flu is very
substantial it said that if they didn't
shake hands that number would be
substantially lower so maybe it'll stay
maybe some of these things long-term
will be good but those guidelines are
still the best and the safest way to
avoid the infection so with the masks
it's going to be really a voluntary
thing you can do it you don't have to do
it I'm choosing not to do it but some
people may want to do it and that's okay
it may be good probably will they're
making a recommendation it's only a
recommendation
it's voluntary we also taking action to
ensure the cost of no barrier to any
Americans seeking testing or treatment
of the coronavirus the largest insurer
nationwide the Blue Cross Blue Shield
System has now announced that it will
not require any co-pays which is really
something that's a tremendous statement
from patients of the virus treatment for
the next 60 days similar to the
commitments of Cigna you manna Anthem
those are great companies and they're
all doing the same thing so co-pays for
them to do that is its big statement we
appreciate it
today I can so proudly announce that
hospitals and health care providers
treating uninsured corona virus patients
will be reimbursed by the federal
government using funds from the economic
relief package Congress passed last
month so that was as per the question
yesterday and actually the day before
yesterday this should alleviate any
concern uninsured Americans may have
about seeking the coronavirus treatment
so that's I think answers the question
pretty well and very much in the favor
of our great people
I'm also signing a directive invoking
the defense production Act to prohibit
export of scarce health and medical
supplies by unscrupulous actors and
profit ears these security and secretary
the Secretary of Homeland Security will
work with FEMA to prevent the export of
n95 respirators surgical masks gloves
and other personal protective equipment
we need these items immediately for
domestic use we have to have them but
we've done really well with the purchase
of items and you'll be hearing about
that shortly
we've already leveraged the DPA to stop
the hoarding and price gouging of
crucial supplies under that authority
this week the Department of Health and
Human Services working with the
Department of Justice took custody of
nearly 200,000 and 95 respirators 130
thousand surgical masks 600,000 gloves
as well as bottles many many many
bottles and disinfectant sprays that
were being courted all of this material
is now being given to healthcare workers
most of his sort have been given out and
we've given a lot to New York a lot to
New Jersey a lot to other places in
addition to ensure that healthcare
workers in New York have the protective
equipment they need the federal
government in the name of the Department
of Defense is providing about 8.1
million in 95 respirators Department of
Defense and we've already given 200,000
of them to New York City
Mayor DeBlasio needed them very badly so
we got him to Mara de Blasio in New York
City and they were very grateful 8.1
million and we're going to be increasing
that number from 8.1 million to more
that's a lot of n95 respirators today my
team spoke with the CEO of our senior
health and the CEO of LCM say the two
largest health systems in New Orleans
they said they feel that they currently
have enough ventilators I think a lot of
people are going to have enough
ventilators and masks and appreciate
what we did and all of the things we've
been doing with them working with them
the CEO of Aashna Warner Thomas who's
really been fantastic I have to say
indicated a need for 230,000 surgical
gowns and I instructed FEMA to deliver
them tomorrow so they have the 230,000
that's Louisiana New Orleans 230,000
surgical gowns they'll have them by
tomorrow we're expanding the role of the
Armed Forces in our response effort
because no one is better prepared to win
a war than the United States military
and we are in a war the invisible enemy
remember over 9,000 retired army medical
personnel have answered their nation's
call and are now supporting field
hospital
and medical facilities all across the
country like what I just told you that
Governor Cuomo requested we do something
and Javits where we take it over and
we're gonna have that manned by the
military because it's very tough to get
people more people in the New York area
so we're gonna have it manned by the
military Javits Center National Guard
members have been activated to help
States build new treatment centers and
assist in the seamless distribution of
medical supplies that includes National
Guard the National Guard is assisting
very strongly because the states were in
many cases unable to have the delivery
capability from warehouses and other
places that we put the supplies so I've
given approval to use the National
Guard's of various National Guard's in
the different states and they're doing a
fantastic job of not only protecting
people but delivering materiel the Army
Corps of Engineers has assessed more
than 100 facilities in all 50 states and
is rapidly building temporary hospitals
and alternative care sites in many
states in New York New Jersey Michigan
Pennsylvania Arizona California Colorado
Florida Illinois New Mexico Oregon
Washington Wisconsin Ohio they're doing
a lot of work in just those states plus
additionals that are being will be
announced probably tomorrow but they're
doing some job the Army Corps of
Engineers what a job they're doing and
FEMA what a job they're doing as we
deploy the power of our military we're
also deploying the skill of our doctors
scientists and medical researchers we
continue to study the effectiveness of
hydroxi chloroquine and other therapies
and the treatment of prevention of the
virus and we will keep the American
people fully informed in our findings
hydroxychloroquine I don't know it's
looking like it's having some good
results I hope that that would be a
phenomenal
but we have it right now in
approximately now it's increased to 1500
people I spoke with dr. Zucker in New
York
terrific guy by the ways we're doing a
good job and I spoke to Governor Cuomo
last evening and this morning about it
so it's been there for about three and a
half days but I think and what many
other places it's being tested to and we
have a tremendous supply of it we've
ordered it in the case that it works and
and it's it could have some pretty big
impact so we'll see what happens my
administration is also working to get
relief to American workers and
businesses and day one of the Paycheck
protection program as Kevin said more
than 3.5 billion dollars in guaranteed
loans have been processed to help small
businesses keep their workers employed
during the unprecedented time this
unprecedented time and Bank of America
has been incredible of the big banks
Bank of America has really stepped
forward and done a great job and then
you have the community banks your
smaller banks and we're already at 3.5
billion dollars going out to incredible
people but that's way ahead of schedule
the SBA and the Treasury are working
around the clock and our banking
partners are really incredible and
they're ensuring that the money gets to
small businesses as quickly as possible
and then the small business in turn take
care of employees that they would have
had to let go and now they'll keep them
and that's good and then they can open
for business and they're gonna have
their employees and we'll try and get
back to where we were eventually we're
gonna supersede where we were the energy
industry has been especially hard hit in
the crisis this afternoon I met with
Greg garland of Phillips 66 Dave Hager
of Devon Energy Harold Hamm of
Continental Resources Jeff Hildebrand of
Hildebrand little petroleum Mike summers
of the American Petroleum Institute
kelsey warren of energy transfer
partners
mic worth of Chevron and Darin Woods of
ExxonMobil I informed them that we will
be making space available in the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve to let
American produce a store surplus oil
that can be sold at a later time there's
a tremendous abundance of oil primarily
because of the virus the viruses just
stopped demand of everything including
oil so we're working with our great
energy companies these are great
companies they employ tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people and
they've kept America really going for a
long time and no big price hikes no big
anything I mean they've just kept it
going and now they got hit but with all
the jobs and all of the good that they
do we're gonna make sure that they stay
in good shape America is engaged in a
historic battle to safeguard the lives
of our citizens our future society our
greatest weapon is the discipline and
determination of every citizen to stay
at home and stay healthy for a long time
and we want them to stay healthy for a
long time so stay at home this is ending
this will end you'll see some bad things
and then you're going to see some really
good things and it's not going to be too
long we will heal our citizens and we
will care for our neighbors and we will
unleash the full might of the United
States of America to vanquish the virus
and with that I'd like to ask Mike Pence
to come up vice president say a few
words and we'll have a couple of other
quick talks on a couple of subjects so
we'll take questions and it's a
beautiful Friday in Washington DC and
our country is a great place and we're
getting better we're getting better very
quickly this was artificially induced we
just said they said close it down and
you have to close it down we closed it
down and we're healing and we're gonna
get it better fast so Mike if you could
come up say if you were
Thank You mr. president president just
outlined a number of the decision that
he made today on the unanimous
recommendation of the white house
coronavirus task force in addition to
some good news dr. deborah birx will
reflect on a moment some of the areas
across america where we see evidence
that the mitigation efforts the american
people putting into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines are
are having a positive effect in fact
today California and Washington state
where the corona virus first emerged in
our country remain the cases remain at a
steady but low rate and we know as
governor Newsom said yesterday that
they're not out of the woods yet and
continue to flow resources but we want
to commend people in those states and
all across the country who are putting
into practice the social distancing and
all the measures that state and local
leaders are advising and that and that
the president has been advising in the
coronavirus guidelines for America we're
also continuing to track significant
outbreaks in New York State New Orleans
Detroit Chicago and Boston and as the
president indicated we're prioritizing
resources to support health care workers
and to support those that are dealing
with the corona virus in those
communities on the subject of testing
now more than 1.4 million tests have
been performed across the country and as
you all are aware some 266 thousand
Americans have tested positive for the
corona virus Abbott instruments which
now can perform a fifteen-minute test
across the country have literally 18,000
of their machines across the nation
today but at the president's Direction
FEMA is acquiring over 1,200 more
machines to distribute to every state
public health lab in America and also to
our indian health care and service and
the big news of course over the last few
days was at the fda once again in near
record time is approved
antibody a test developed by SELEX and
we're continuing on the white house
coronavirus task force to examine ways
that we can scale up these rapid tests
and these innovative new tests not just
to meet this moment but to lay a
foundation for testing across the nation
in the months ahead as the president
mentioned he met with energy executives
today and continues to engage with
leaders of businesses all across the
nation we also held two held a
teleconference today with commercial
retailers on the president's behalf we
thanked them for the way that people
that operate malls and shopping centers
around the country have have have have
embraced and enacted the coronavirus
guidelines of for America it's had an
enormous impact on their businesses and
their industries but I heard I heard
from them they're their patriotic
commitment to put the health of their
associates and their customers first and
it was deeply inspiring on the subject
of supplies the president detailed our
work in that space it continues to this
day
part of our air bridge we had a flight
arrived from China today to Columbus
Ohio we continue to work each and every
day watching the data about cases to
ensure that in particular not just the
personal protective equipment is
available for the health care workers
that are on the front lines but also
that ventilators are available as the as
as this epidemic makes its way through
through regions and communities we are
literally working hour by hour day by
day to make sure that patients families
and health care providers have the
equipment and the support that they need
as the president mentioned we've we've
seen over a billion and a half dollars
and loans go out through the paycheck
protection program today we have
available for questions the head of the
CDC today to speak about the new
guidance on cloth face coverings and
secretary a czar in a few moments we'll
lean
just--how the president's decision to
make sure that no American will ever
have to worry about paying for testing
or for coronavirus treatment I'm pleased
to report at the president's Direction
Medicaid and Medicare already expanded
to coronavirus treatment and testing
early on and of course the president
just indicated how major insurance
companies across the country are not
just waiving co-pays on testing but
they're now waiving co-pays for at least
60 days on any any coronavirus treatment
but now as secretary Hayes our will
enumerate and now we'll make sure that
any American even those that have no
insurance will be able to receive
treatment in a hospital and never have
to worry about the bill I just give a
gentle reminder to every American if
there is evidence across the country
that you're putting into practice the
coronavirus guidelines for America every
American has a role to play and I want
to thank you on behalf of the President
and and and all of the American people
for the way that you're stepping forward
you're engaging in the social distancing
and doing the things that will slow the
spread we encourage you to keep on
keeping on we will get through this
America we will get through the
coronavirus to that day of renewed
health renewed prosperity that the
president always describes but we'll get
through there sooner and we'll get
through there when we work together
Thank You mr. vice president mr.
president thank you for your words of
discipline and determination I guess
that really describes what we're asking
every American and to really be
disciplined about these guidelines and
really determined to stay in that space
of execution you know we are just in
week three of this full guidance measure
we really do appreciate the work of the
citizens of California and Washington
State because we do see that their curve
is different their curve is different
from New York New Jersey and can
etiquette and we really believe that the
work that every citizen is doing in
those states is making a difference and
it will make a difference for the
frontline health care providers we also
are deeply grateful that despite the way
their curve looks today they continue to
get ready for a different potential so
that they can ensure that patients if
they do get sick have options and
availability to all the frontline health
care workers in the what we have
referred to as hot zones areas where the
number of cases are quite significant
the New Orleans the New York City metro
area including New Jersey and
Connecticut the incredible work that the
frontline health care workers are
providing we've really working now at a
much more granular level talking
directly to hospitals to ensure that
they have the supplies that they need in
coordination with state state and local
governments and to work I think we
discussed it yesterday but I think it
was quite clear also and reiterated by
Governor Cuomo today that we have to
support one another as each of these
different metro areas and other areas
move through their peak of new
infections when we talked about it at
the beginning of this week we talked
about this week and next week being
incredibly difficult and we want to
recognize the number of Americans who
have lost their lives to this virus and
recognize the sacrifice that healthcare
providers are making both in their care
but I think we're I'm very uplifted by
hearing their messages to families and
their compassion for others to provide
that kind of support to the individuals
in the hospital we continue to watch in
addition the Chicago area the Detroit
area and have some developing concerns
around Colorado the District of Columbia
and Pennsylvania so as you can see each
of these will follow their own curves
will be getting more and more of those
case overtime information in a very
granular way to each and every one of
you so that we can
follow these epidemic edema logic curves
as each of these states counties and
communities move through this together
in solidarity and really ensuring that
we can move supplies creatively around
the country to meet the needs of both
the frontline healthcare providers but
also every American who needs our
support right now thank you thank you
well thank you mr. president for your
continued leadership as we battle the
corona virus first I want to thank all
of the members of the HHS team and the
frontline healthcare workers across
America including those who those
service workers who serve in our
hospitals and our health care facilities
those who clean those who deliver those
who stock the shelves all those who are
going into battle every day against the
virus your countries asked you to serve
as never before and you have responded
heroically I'm gonna provide a brief
update on the administration's plans to
cover the testing and treatment for the
uninsured getting the uninsured access
to the care they need is a top priority
for President Trump we are already
rolling out the 1 billion dollars in
funding from the families first
coronavirus response Act to cover
provider's expenses for testing and
diagnosing the uninsured the cares Act
signed by the president includes another
100 billion dollars for health care
providers under the president's
direction we will use a portion of that
funding to cover provider's costs of
delivering kovat 19 care for the
uninsured sending the money to providers
through the same mechanism used for
testing as a condition of receiving
funds under this program providers will
be forbidden from balanced billing the
uninsured for the cost of their care
providers will be reimbursed at Medicare
rates we will soon up more specifics on
how the rest of the 100 billion dollars
will go to providers we're working to
ensure that this funding is distributed
in a way that is fast fair simple and
transparent
I'd also like to remind people that if
you've lost employer insurance coverage
you have insurance options that you
should look into you'd be eligible for a
special enrollment period on the health
care exchanges and depending on your
state you may be eligible for Medicaid
just as president Trump is working to
ensure that kovat 19 treatment is paid
for he's working to support new
treatment options for patients thanks to
the president's leadership many
providers are trying different
experimental therapies and we need as
much data as we can collect as quickly
as possible on how these treatments are
working
today Oracle has developed and is
donating to the government and the
American people a web portal and
platform to gather crowd-sourced
real-time information from providers
about how patients respond to potential
therapeutics well this doesn't replace
the important work of clinical trials it
gives us data rapidly if you are a
doctor or a health care provider and you
would like to help us you can sign up
today to begin reporting on your work
there's a special registration page for
providers at kovat 19 dot oracle.com
thank you very much okay let's go on
face masks what do what would people
gain from wearing a mask and why are you
opposed to wearing one yourself
I just don't myself it's a
recommendation they recommend it I'm
feeling good I just don't want to be
doing I don't know somehow sitting in
the Oval Office behind that beautiful
resolute desk the great resolute desk
I think wearing a face mask as I greet
presidents prime ministers dictators
kings queens I don't know somehow I
don't see it for myself I just I just
maybe I'll change my mind but this will
pass and hopefully it'll pass very
quickly now with that being said if
somebody wants to most people can just
make something out of
certain material so it's very well
designated it's very simple to do I
won't be doing it personally
it's a recommendation okay Surgeon
General please Thank You mr. president
mr. vice president mr. secretary and CDC
director Redfield I especially want to
thank the folks at the CDC and it's a
great question that you asked it's a
fair question that you asked I want to
unpack the evolution of our guidance on
mass because it has been confusing to
the American people first of all I want
people to understand that the CDC the
World Health Organization my office in
most public health and health
organizations and professionals
originally recommended against the
general public wearing masks because
based on the best evidence available at
the time it was not deemed that that
would have a significant impact on
whether or not a healthy person wearing
a mask would contract kovat 19 we have
always recommended that symptomatic
people wear a mask because if you're
coughing if you have a fever if you're
symptomatic you could transmit disease
to other people what has changed in our
recommendation well it's important to
know that we now know from recent
studies that a significant portion of
individuals with corona virus lack
symptoms they're what we call
asymptomatic and that even those who
eventually become pre-symptomatic
meaning that they will develop symptoms
in the future can transmit the virus to
others before they show symptoms this
means that the virus can spread between
people interacting in close proximity
for example coughing speaking or
sneezing even if those people were not
exhibiting symptoms in light of this new
evidence CDC recommends and the Task
Force recommends wearing cloth face
coverings in public public settings
where other social distancing measures
are difficult to maintain these these
include places like grocery stores and
pharmacies we especially recommend this
in areas of significant community based
transmission it is critical and the
president meant
in this the vice-president mentioned
this it's critical to emphasize that
maintaining six feet of social
distancing remains key to slowing the
spread of the virus but CDC is
additionally advising the use of simple
cloth coverings to slow the spread of
the virus and to help people who may
have the virus and do not know it shrimp
from transmitting it to others the
cloths face coverings recommended or not
surgical masks are in 95 respirators
those are critical supplies that must
continue to be reserved for healthcare
workers and other medical first
responders as recommended by the current
CDC guidance as the president also
mentioned cloths face coverings
fashioned from household items are made
at home from common materials at low
cost can be used as an additional
voluntary public health measure and this
recommendation complements and does not
replace the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America 30 days to slow
the spread which remains the cornerstone
of our national effort to slow the
spread of the virus
CDC is always always looking at the data
we've told you that from the beginning
dr. Burke says it every single press
conference we're looking at the data
we're evolving our recommendations and
new recommendations will come as the
evidence dictates so I want to say if
you do choose to wear a face mask very
important wash your hands first because
you don't want to put on a face covering
with a dirty hand do not touch your face
while you are wearing the face covering
because again you could take materials
from the surface germs from the surface
and bring it to your face if you choose
to wear a face covering please please
leave the n95 mask the medical supplies
for the medical professionals health
care workers and frontline workers know
that this is not a substitute for social
distancing and remember this is all
about me protecting you and you
protecting me this is about us coming
together as communities and if people
voluntarily choose to wear a face face
covering they're wearing it to protect
their neighbors from getting the corona
virus because again they could have
asymptomatic spread so mr. president
thank you very much for that appreciate
the opportunity to update
okay Joe mr. president dr. foxy Laughlin
recommended said that every state should
have stay-at-home orders right now do
you agree with that should every state
in this country have to kind of stay in
home words that we now see places like
walking up to the governor's the
governor's know what they're doing
they've been doing a great job
I guess we're close to 90 percent anyway
and states that we're talking about are
not in jeopardy now I would leave it to
the governor's like I like that from the
standpoint of governing and I like that
from the standpoint of even our
Constitution Drug Administration
announced yesterday right we'll get you
later what to the oil meeting previous
is the u.s. willing to cut domestic oil
production what came out of the meeting
what was the consent well a lot of
things came out it's a great industry
it's an important industry to tremendous
job producing industry and it's just
vital and it was also very interesting
because they all were given the test
before they came into the room so you
have the head of ExxonMobil you have all
these guys taking the test and they all
passed with flying colors so that was
good
they left happy in that respect at least
there's just an overabundance of oil
right now
oil and gas tremendous overabundance and
it was caused they were doing a great
job they were producing a lot of energy
but then you had the virus come along
and it knocked another 35% maybe 40% off
of the market so there's too much oil
there's a glut and these are great
companies and they'll figure it out
spree market will figure it out you
spoke to President Putin
I mean what's on the table here they
were having a competition we'll see how
it all works out I think it's going to
work out very well it's going to take a
long time to to get rid of that this
massive excess amount of oil and gas
massive like probably there's never been
so where that does work out well I guess
you could say is for drivers I think in
certain locations it's down to
ninety and ninety five cents a gallon
right down the road but we have a
tremendous industry a great industry a
tremendously important industry from the
standpoint of jobs and we're energy
independent we have to make sure we keep
it that way all right
drug administration to address the sort
of blood supply announced yesterday will
ease the restrictions on certain donors
including gay men or now required to be
abstinent for three months as opposed to
twelve months to donate a hand a vessel
no I didn't know anything about that
that was done by the FDA very capable
people at the FDA yes mr. president
both the Government of Canada and 3m are
pushing back on this DPA not to export
n95 respirators yeah
3m says I don't blame them they can push
back at once we're not happy with 3m
yeah I'm not happy and the people that
dealt with it directly are not at all
happy with 3m so we'll see whether or
not we do I heard what he had to say
today I don't know the gentlemen but
we're not happy with 3m go ahead and
where is dr. pouchy I don't know
but every time you ask that question
whenever he's not here you look you say
where is he
and you'll say is there a problem no
problem whatsoever
every time he's not here sometimes I'll
ask him to come because that's the first
question that you and a couple of others
from the fake news establishment ask is
we're stocked fhe we're doing great
together
we're covering a different subject today
go ahead go ahead yeah president you
have said nobody could have seen this
pandemic coming but in fact secretary a
czar at a bio defense summit in April 20
19 said of course the people of course
the thing that people asked what keeps
you most up at night in the bio defense
world pandemic flu of course I think
everyone in this room probably shares
that concern your own Health and Human
Services Secretary was aware that this
had the potential of being a very big
problem around the world a pandemic of
this nature who dropped the ball well I
always knew that pandemics are one of
the worst things could happen there's
been nothing like this since probably
1917 that was
the big one in Europe it started
actually here and went to Europe
probably I've heard about she has made
wait a minute let me finish I've heard
about this for a long time pandemics you
don't want pandemics and I don't think
he was talking about a specific pandemic
he was talking about the threat of a
pandemic could happen and it could
happen most people thought it wouldn't
and most people didn't understand the
severity of it this is very severe
what's happened is very severe but I'd
let you answer that I assume that he was
talking about the concept of a pandemic
Thank You mr. president accurate
absolutely for 15 years now this country
is at a massive effort at the federal
state and local level of preparedness
for pandemic now that largely has been
as I said in those remarks about
pandemic flu preparedness we knew about
SARS we knew about MERS which were
earlier modifications of variants of the
corona virus none of those achieved
anything like what we're seeing today
but that's why for successive
presidencies including the leadership of
President Trump there has been a great
focus on pandemic preparedness in fact
it was just in November I believe that
the President signed the pandemic flu
preparedness executive order that we
have we've and we have also updated the
pandemic crisis action plan which has
been the playbook from which we've been
working the pandemic flu plan the again
the action plan from which we have been
working that coordinates the
whole-of-government whole of economy
approach here so we've all been very
focused on pandemic preparedness that's
what we do but this particular strain of
pandemic who would who would have known
this particular strain but secretaries
are if you are preparing for a pandemic
of this government we're preparing for a
pandemic why is it we don't have enough
mass why is it we don't have enough
medical equipment and the previous
administrations gave us very little
ammunition for the military and very
little shelf spend let me just tell you
you know it you know the answer the
previous administration the shelves were
empty the shelves were empty so what you
should do is speak to the people from
the previous administration Jim and ask
him
question because the shelves were at the
ANU no one else the military shelves
were also empty
we had no ammunition literally that was
said by one of your favorite generals we
have sir we have no ammunition guess
what we had very little medical supply
also all right we'll get you back what
you my SID we'll get you back please
so you said that there will be a ban on
exporting of all what does it cover it
so masks gloves what else are you but if
somebody ordered if Italy if Spain who
has big problems these have these are
countries with tremendous problems
France if they ordered if they have long
term orders and they're in there and
they want to get certain things I've let
them go out in certain instances because
I think it's only fair they have
problems that are proportionately or
relatively bigger than our problems so
if they ordered something and they're
waiting for as an example masks made
here and going to Italy I'm not going to
be stopping that I think would be very
unfair and by the way speaking about
being fair and unfair to very big cruise
liners as you know I allowed them to
dock today we worked with the governor
of Florida as you know run to Santos and
we worked on it and we had tremendous
security and we took the sick people and
we're working with them we have doctors
we have great doctors military doctors
and from a humane standpoint not that
we're in love with this these are two
massive ships but we have to take care
of people we have to take care of we
sent many back to Canada the candidate
the Canadians came and worked very
closely with us as did the UK we had a
lot of people from the UK and we take we
took care of the Americans we took care
of the sick we had some people very sick
I think we had three to four maybe five
people that had died on the boat that
one of the boats actually and we had to
take care of these people so we could
have let him float aimlessly into the
ocean looking for port as they've been
doing for a long time and I made the
decision we had to take him in and
Homeland Security and a lot of other
people did a great job but
we had to help people these are people
that were very very sick some were dying
some died your staff they said that
people close proximity to you and the
vice president will get a corona virus
test I'm wondering are you concerned
that the people you've been hanging
around with may have the virus
no I'm not concerned no yeah I had a
test yesterday for the order for people
who meet with you or talk to you I heard
from the oil executives these are people
most of them had not had the test and
frankly I think they left the room
feeling good about a lot of things but
they felt good about the test this was a
test it took I guess 13 minutes to have
it finalized say they took the test I
don't know I didn't know they were doing
that maybe they did it just for them I
don't know but it seems that a lot of
people because now we have tests that
really worked well Abbott in this case
habit we have other tests being
developed right now that are also
fantastic the original tests the ones we
inherited Jim is an example they were
they were broken they were obsolete they
were not good tests and that's what we
got stuck with we've developed some
incredible tests but this took 13 to 15
minutes
and they were all fine the problem some
people have raised is that if the u.s.
stopped exporting what you could have is
other countries then deciding
reciprocally that they are going to stop
exporting and then the result of that
then will be a net decrease in the
amount of supplies that American doctors
American hospitals have how do you
address that
well I dress it in the following manner
we really are very well supplied we are
not the principal it's the hospital's
the states the cities they're supposed
to get everything they can and stock up
in case something like this happens but
nobody could ever have assumed that
something like this happened so we
started supplying we brought tremendous
amounts to New York today and over the
last few days we brought them to
Louisiana
we brought them to Michigan we brought
them to Los Angeles a lot of equipment
you've read the amount of masks that we
had I think I said over 8 million masks
the n95 masks they you know more
expensive more complicated better what
masks the ones they want to use in the
hospitals we have millions of them now
and we've given them to a lot we sent to
Bellevue in New York today
that was for mayor de Blasio 200,000 of
them but we have 8.1 million we're going
to have more than that and we're getting
them from various sources including the
military we're rapidly then replacing
them because we have to replace them in
case there's a another emergency I would
be of gowns too we have many gowns being
delivered and have been delivered our
people have done an incredible job
most people have said now and and I said
this yesterday governors have said thank
you very much great job if they're a
Democrat governor in some cases not in
all cases at all if I said here's a
thousand ventilators how many do you
want we want 1,000 here's a thousand you
got them but you know what we're gonna
do we're going to add another 5,000 is
that good they said wow that's great
and then if Jim Acosta goes and says are
you happy with the president no we
should have given us 10,000 that's
what's happening you know why because
that's a standard political answer and
that's a shame because we have done a
job like nobody's ever done a job but
we've just delivered a lot of masks
we've just delivered a lot of gowns and
protective gear but you know you're
talking about a massive you're talking
about a massive number but as of this
morning people were very very happy
Steve asked you for a bailout it was
really more of a discussion than asking
we just got you know we did discuss the
concept of tariffs because as you know
this was a dispute among a couple of
countries that I think they want to be
able to get it solved and they had a
dispute they had a competition but they
want to get a reserve Russia and Saudi
Arabia I think they want to get it yeah
I think they want to get it resolved I
think they're working very hard I mean
they told me they want to get it
resolved they're working very hard
thank you yesterday Jared Kushner said
the notion of the federal stockpile was
it supposed to be our stockpile it's not
supposed to be state stockpiles that
they then use what did he mean by our
you know what our means the United
States of America that's what it means
it means our our it means the United
States of America and then we take that
our and we distribute it to the states
nothing not supposed to be state
stockpiles because we need it for the
government and we needed for the federal
government but when the states are in
charge no to also keep to keep to keep
for our country because the federal
government needs a - not just the states
but out of that we oftentimes choose as
an example we have almost 10,000
ventilators and we are ready to rock
with those ventilators we're going to
bring them to various areas of the
country that need them but when he says
our he's talking about our country he's
talking excuse me he's talking about the
federal government I mean it's such a
basic simple question and you try and
make it sound so bad you ought to be you
ought to be ashamed of yourself you know
what you're too bishop it's such a
simple question
he said hour an hour means for the
country an hour means for the states
because the states are a part of the
country don't make it sound bad don't
make it sound bad go ahead Steve go
ahead back here
you just ask you a question you just ask
you a question in a very nasty tone
let's go mr. president give you a
perfect answer you know it go ahead
what's it just to follow up on that when
when we have the federal stock file I
mean isn't that designed to be able to
distribute to the state sure but it's
also needed for the federal government
we have a federal stockpile and they
have state stockpiles and frankly they
were many of the states were totally
unprepared for this so we had to go into
the federal stockpile but we're not an
ordering clerk they have to have for
themselves now some of the states were
in good shape some of the states we're
not in good shape that's probably
something you could expect
we have been helping States we have been
spending a tremendous amount of time
effort and billions and billions of
dollars when making sure that they have
what they have I mean take New York we
built them hospitals I built them for
hospitals built a medical centers sent a
ship with a thousand rooms than twelve
operating rooms and and then on top of
that gave vast numbers of ventilators
and vast numbers of surgical gowns
equipment masks everything else now they
had a chance to order ventilators over
the years they had a chance to order a
very big but they didn't choose to do it
we were there and we helped them and I
think the governor of New York is very
thankful for the help that we gave but
we have a stockpile it's a federal
stockpile we can use that for States or
we can use it for ourselves we do use it
for the federal government we have a
very big federal government going to use
their powers to be essentially a traffic
cop for all the essential medical
supplies they're a traffic cop we're a
humanitarian Cup we help it's like the
ships do you think we wanted to take two
big ships into our country that have
obvious problems and you know the
problems I'm talking about so I have a
decision to make
do I take them in or do I save lives
okay do I take them in or do I said I
decided to take them in and we have
tremendous protection we have great
doctors there to help the people they
had four or five people that died
that was as of last night they died in
the ships we took care of it
and now the people are in the process of
and many are already back in Canada that
back in the UK United Kingdom and many
of them were American citizens some were
very sick we're taking care of the sick
people we're testing all of the others
very very carefully very very carefully
they are being tested like you wouldn't
believe
and we solve a humanitarian catastrophe
you know why because nobody else would
take the ships nobody else would take
them so we dr. bin
I think Fort Lauderdale why why you
don't say we're the federal government's
and there's a shortage of massive things
and we're going we do say that we so we
say and we use the act excuse me we do
say that and we use the act and we've
used it a number of times very
powerfully and a lot of times we don't
have to use it because we say we're
going to use it if you don't do this or
that and then we also have companies
that act incredibly well we have plenty
of them mostly them but we've used the
act very powerfully and a lot of times
you don't have to exercise the act all
you have to do is tell look if you don't
do this we're going to use the act and
we've done a good job with it maybe a
great job yeah mr. president there are
news reports that you want to sign the
stimulus checks that are going out here
in several months is that right I know
there's millions of checks I'm gonna
sign them no it's a trump administration
initiative but do I want to sign him no
the people are getting to people are
getting their money there's a lot of
stimulus going in a lot of different
ways there's also stimulus going for
companies that would if it weren't for
our government would not and some
companies that were very strong a month
ago again we had the strongest economy
in the world we had our best ever we had
probably the best economy in the history
of the world bigger than China bigger
than anybody and one day we have to say
close it up stop everybody go home and
you know what it's pretty tough to do
that
these chicks may not go out for another
four months well I can tell you is this
small business today as they were way
ahead of schedule there is a problem we
ran which I pointed out I said you
shouldn't do this way with unemployment
we're 40 year old equipment by the
states we're sending the money to the
states once the money is sent to the
states in the States whether they're
Republican or Democrat have to get the
money out to the people hopefully they
will be able to do it but many of those
states have 40 year old computers I
don't know that they're equipped I
wanted to give the money directive
that's what you're talking about I
wanted to give the money out direct it
would have been much easier but the
Democrats and some people said no let's
do social distancing first of all this
is for yourself and doctor burse what
percentage of the population do we
suspect to be asymptomatic at this point
so our way to to figure that out it
seems like the antibody test might be
able to assist thank you so while we're
working diligently in the midst of the
crisis to make sure that the healthcare
workers and everyone who is sick gets
provided for at the same time we're
working on tests and assays that will be
critical for surveillance and at the
same time working on plans for what we
need to do as this moves through the
population and we get on the downside
where we're not there yet
and hopefully most of the states will
say like California and Washington and
then what will you need to do to be
prepared for fall so all three of those
things are happening simultaneously and
there's people working on each one of
those work streams the antibody piece is
critical as you described because at
this time we can't if we have let's say
asymptomatic status is inversely
asymptomatic status is inversely related
to age
and so the younger you are the more
likely you are to be asymptomatic we
have to know that because we have to
know how many people have actually
become infected so when we talked about
five days ago I think on Monday
I called on universities to work on
analyzer based test to test for their
their health workers and really get
through that at the same time the
private sector is working on tests and
what do we want those tests to be we
want those tasks to be like what we use
for HIV and malaria finger prick onto a
cassette you get a line if you're
positive and you get a control line
negative the line isn't there and
there's the control line that's what
that's our dream assay because it's a
finger prick in the meantime we're not
waiting I mean we're pushing for that at
the same time we're asking to develop an
assay the Eliza based assay which
requires a tube of blood and that's why
we're also talking about could we use
dried blood spots we also put our call
directly out to the military because of
the Roosevelt to really test all of the
sailors on the Roosevelt with an
antibody test to get to this critical
issue of asymptomatic and already
pre-existing antibody that would be if
the first responders knew they already
had had it and they had protective
antibody if the nurses knew the doctors
knew if your schoolteacher knew then
it's a very different dialogue so we
understand the importance of that and we
understand how important it is in
relationship to understanding this
epidemic one other comment because I I
know we're always saying who knew what
when I just want to make clear there's a
hundred and fifty plus countries working
on this collectively together it's
devastating for every single country
when we get through this we can go back
and look at what happened where and and
what does this epidemic look like then
when you get through it then you can
validate every model there is known to
man when you're in the middle of it you
have to concentrate on serving the needs
of each American
and what that need looks like at the
same time you have these other work
streams on surveillance and how to be
prepared both scientifically and
therapeutically and vaccine wise for the
next fall if that happens again so I
think these things are happening
together but I just want us to really
concentrate on the fact that all around
the globe country after country is
dealing with this and we can talk about
why didn't Italy do something or Spain
do something or Germany do something or
we can really say right now we can do
something we can do the social
distancing and all of the pieces that we
know is starting to work around the
globe in country after country and then
when we get through all of this we can
ask the questions about could we have
done some piece of this better as a
global community I will remind you that
on February 3rd the head of the w-h-o
said there was no reason to ever do a
travel ban you know it wasn't until
January 14th that we knew that there was
human to human transmission remember
president was saying this was going to
go away it's April this president you
said it was going to go in away in April
you said no no no that was a log but a
very good answer that was enough users
government mr. president on the
insurance coverage for treatment when
your government is going is trying to
make sure that people are covered on the
treatment we're going to them does that
include the 11 million people who are in
this country illegally as well about
that at a different time yet please go
yes sir
mr. president will you release authorize
the release of
the underlying data for the conclusion
of the 100,000 and 240,000 people
succumbing perhaps dr. Burks cannula
supply works these experts have
expressed concern that they haven't seen
the underlying data they're not sure
they'll talk to you about that and dr.
fat you too please Thank You mr.
president
this is for you and secretary aids are
um 10 million people say they've lost
their jobs in the past two weeks so how
is this the newest money for free
treatment going to absorb the new
numbers of uninsured and would it not be
easier to do reopen the Obama care
markets or expand Medicaid so for an
individual who had employer insurance
that's what I mentioned in my remarks if
you were employed and had insurance
through your employer and you've now
lost your job and lost that insurance
you now do have a special enrollment
period where you may enroll in the
individual exchanges of the Affordable
Care Act so that's that's existing law
then what we're doing is taking from
that hundred billion dollars to
providers taking money and saying if
you're a provider and you care for
anybody who's uninsured we're going to
compensate you for doing that and we're
gonna compensate you at the Medicare
reimbursement rates and you are not
allowed to build that uninsured
individual anything so in many respects
it's better for those uninsured
individuals they're gonna get first
dollar coverage they're gonna get care
in the United States and the provider is
gonna be made whole from this program so
it's really an unprecedented on what
President Trump is doing here with this
money is an unprecedented
disease-specific
support of care for individuals to make
sure that people get treatment
specifically on New York and the
question of ventilators Governor Cuomo
was saying that New York may be days
away a truck from running out of
ventilators can you assure New York that
going into next week they're gonna have
to
they're gonna need no they should have
had more ventilators at the time they
should have had more ventilators they
were totally under serviced we are
trying to do we're doing our best for
New York you know we have we have States
we have a lot of states we have
territories to but we have a lot of
states that have to be taken care of
some much more so than others we've
worked very well with the governor we
happen to think that he's well served
with ventilators we're gonna find out
but we have other states to take care of
we have a big problem in Louisiana we
have a big problem in Michigan we have a
big problem and seven other really
strong hot spots but we're doing the
best we can I wish they did the original
orders three years ago they would have
had all the ventilators they needed
although even then they wouldn't because
if you look at what the original request
was from New York it was far greater
than anybody ever heard and we've we've
supplied a lot I told you we supplied
some just today to New York and we
supplied some yesterday to New York City
are so important I don't think Bob is it
it was a very important question because
what Jared Kushner said yesterday is
that the federal stockpile is for use by
the federal government not for the
states to have access to so you seem to
be saying different than the Jerry
cooker misspeak yesterday no he's that
famous stockpile he used the word hour
okay our hours referring to our country
the states to the best of my knowledge
and to the best of your knowledge are a
part of our country we are taking what
is in the federal stockpile and we are
helping States all over the country but
we also want to keep some because when
that surge comes when you hit those
peaks we're going to need we have to be
able to have the flexibility to take
those ventilators and bring them to
Louisiana New York Detroit different
places that's all but the words we're
not using them anywhere else we're not
gonna be using them John anywhere else
but we want the flexibility because you
know we don't even know when the surge
is coming but it's coming soon and it's
gonna be big and some areas won't have
it some areas will be pleasantly
surprised just like we've been you look
at the chart
states that I thought would have been
maybe a disaster turned out to be really
they've done a great job some states are
really trouble but you don't know you
don't know we have great flexibility
I would have preferred giving them all
out we have nothing and now when we have
a surge we can't get them back from
where we gave it because it's very tough
to take them back so we have tremendous
flexibility and it could be New York it
could be Louisiana those are two that
are really rough New Jersey is very
rough and they've done a very good job
in New Jersey but New Jersey's rough go
ahead please to which group and so on
and now we have this this measure about
wearing masks and I know you told Steve
about why you don't want to wear a mask
but I'm just wondering if you can tell
us more about why it because it was for
example they're not mandatory guidelines
they're guidelines they suggest you
could wear them you don't have to wear
them in fact the director is here if you
want to say a couple of words about it
you know you can if you want you don't
have to but basically it's it's a
voluntary thing directly done a good job
thank you very much I think I just want
to re-emphasize I've said this before
that we're not defenseless against this
virus we have a powerful tool a powerful
weapon that is social distancing and
we've continued to embrace that with the
president's initiatives to slow the
spread of Carano virus we're constantly
looking at new data and as the Surgeon
General said one of the new information
that became more clear to all of us is
there's a greater number of people that
are asymptomatic aliy infected than we
previously thought as ambassador birx
said that may be inversely related to
age and so really the purpose here is
first and foremost to embrace the social
distancing that's the number one thing
that's the powerful weapon and you know
this virus has a great weakness it can't
jump from one person to another if it's
got to swim more than six feet and this
is why we really want that that said we
now know that there may be individuals
in significant a significant community
transmission that may be asymptomatic
aliy infected and we know that
a face barrier and actually interrupts
the number of virus particles that can
go for one person to the other so as was
said by the vice-president this is in
the president the purpose of this face
covering is to be another objective
mitigation strategy to protect someone
from spreading the virus from themselves
to someone else and I was just tested
also so I assumed I don't have the virus
so I'd have to worry about spreading it
okay
please mr. president I want to make sure
we're clear when you mentioned tariffs
earlier they came up in a meeting
are you considering tariffs on Saudi
Arabian oil and they look tariffs have
made a tremendous amount of money for
our country I put them on China I put
them on other places and other countries
tariffs US and they take advantage of us
and they have for many years
look countries have taken advantage of
the United States for years they've
ripped us off like nobody can even
believe whether it be on on
manufacturing whether it be on exporting
whether it be on almost anything
including military well we provide
virtually free military assistance to
countries that frankly take advantage of
us don't even like us okay so this has
been going on for years
they tariffs us they create artificial
you could say non-financial barriers
which are worse than financial barriers
you can't sell your product you can't
take care of our farmers they won't take
our and yet they'll take us and sell
into us and we won't charge them
anything for doing it look they've taken
advantage of us for years tariffs are a
way of evening the score tariffs are a
way of just neutralizing they have
tariffs on us and we now can put tariffs
on them am I using it for oil it's
something we can know am i doing it now
no am I thinking about imposing it as of
this moment no but if we're not treated
fairly it's certainly a tool in the
toolbox and what about with Russia are
you what you consider may be lifting
sanctions or giving some sanctions
now it'd be the same thing they are
having a dispute the two countries and
it's hurting the rest of the world
because it's really hurting the energy
industry Russia's being hurt
unbelievably badly and Saudi Arabia's
being hurt unbelievably badly because
oil and gas is a primary that's where
they get most of their income and this
is a price like from the 1950s all right
it's a price from the 1950s they are
being hurt very badly I think they're
gonna settle their dispute pretty
quickly production that's what they've
done they've increased it so much that
this so you meant the opposite well
they're going to stop because the market
ultimately the market is going to get
them to stop but they both did the
opposite they increase production to a
level that water is right now more
valuable than oil who would have ever
thought right you go to you go to some
of these kingdoms water is far more
valuable than oil there's so much oil
it's a tribute in a way but what
happened is there was a lot to start off
with and then you had the virus and it
knocked the hell out of the market it in
terms of demand so there's no demand and
this tremendous supply so I mean you saw
numbers where it was down to 20 and down
frankly below 20 it was even below 20
it's an incredible thing the market but
ultimately the marketplace will take
care of it but I think they're gonna
work out their problem fairly quickly
okay mr. president Thank You mr.
president
um we're already talking about phase
four of a stimulus right but you and
Pelosi and McConnell are already talking
about different things that should be in
it now last time people were telling me
that the fact that you wouldn't talk to
Pelosi
an impediment and it really slowed
things down are you talking who we're
important to talk to I talk to her if it
were important for the American people I
talked to her but other than that I can
have other people talking to her look
were you ready infrastructure is a great
thing for me
I think infrastructure for this country
we have an old broken infrastructure 50
years ago we were the envy of the world
and then we spent all this money so
stupidly in the Middle East we spent
it's going to be very close to eight
trillion dollars in the Middle East how
stupid was that decision but they spent
it on that and other things we've got to
fix our infrastructure that means roads
highways tunnels airports everything we
got to fix our interest and the beauty
is because of the fact that we are so
strong as a country we're borrowing at
zero we never had a chance to borrow
it's here even this country we've never
had a chance to borrow zero we're gonna
borrow this is a great time so we can
fix our infrastructure and we'll have
almost no interest cost this is the time
to do it
Steve one more question you told
projection that you shared with us
earlier this week are we still on the
current trajectory for that or have so
which one I think from anything 4,100 to
40,000 are we still on that trajectory
or and we made any improvements or maybe
not enough same saying
have we made enough and I'd have to ask
dr. Fauci and I'd have to ask Deborah
have the models changed so a lot of the
projections you can see are based on
there's many different ways to look at
this and as we discussed on Sunday some
of it is based on the current global
experience we are about I think six
point five or five point five times the
size of Italy a different factor in
Spain and we look at all of those what
their projections are where they are
currently and where that is going and so
a lot of the work is based on how this
virus has moved through other
populations that's a very direct way to
see how the virus is
impacting uh populations there's also
terrific models and so everyday and
everynight one of the models that
actually looks at the model related to
mortality is the health data org data
and they updated every night and you can
see where we are in that projection I
think in the last run of that model they
were at 93 thousand or something in the
model now all of that can be changed by
our behaviors and so and all of it can
be changed in a different way if we
don't follow those behaviors if another
major metropolitan area ends up having
an epidemic like the New York metro area
that could dramatically change not the
model but the reality of the impact of
this virus on Americans the
professionals did the models I was never
involved in a model but it's this kind
of a model but you know what hundreds of
thousands of people they say that I want
much less than that I want none but it's
too late for that but I want very few
people relative to what the models are
saying those are projections I hope
they're wrong I hope we're going to be
under those projections two questions on
continuity of governments have to wait
can you have one well they're real ab10
I have three questions I have two quick
can you give me one instead because get
a couple of other papers good okay I'll
go in my second one
the Governor of Wisconsin is now talking
about delaying the primary at least not
having a person voting so my question is
and I asked us a couple weeks ago wanna
see if you've made any progress on this
looking ahead to the fall are you taking
steps to ensure that the general
election will happen even if this
pandemic has re-emerged or hasn't gone
away the general it sure will happen on
November 3rd in Wisconsin what happened
is I through social media media put out
a very strong endorsement of a
Republican conservative judge who's an
excellent brilliant judge he's a justice
and I here what happened is his poll
numbers went through the roof and
because of that I think they delayed the
elections for going to in-person I don't
know he why didn't he do it before he's
doing right before the election do you
think scuse me why did he do this two
weeks ago all of a sudden a kismet all
of a sudden an election which is taking
place very soon gets delayed now I just
endorsed him today and it was a very
strong endorsement his polls he's gone
very high up and all of a sudden the
governor comes out the Democrat governor
by the way comes out says oh we're gonna
move this election so I don't know I'm
sure I hope you're right IOP what do you
think every state in this country should
be prepared for mail-in voting no a lot
of people cheat with mail-in voting I
think people should vote with ID voter
ID
I think voter ID is very important and
the reason they don't want voter ID is
because they intend to cheat when you
get something when you buy something you
look at your cards and credit cards and
different cards you have your picture
and many of them not all of them but are
many of them you should have a picture
on your on your voting it should be
called voter ID they should have that
and it shouldn't be mail and excuse me
it shouldn't be mail-in voting it should
be you go to a booth and you proudly
display yourself you don't send it in
the mail where people pick up all sorts
of bad things can happen by the time
they sign that if they sign that if they
sign that by the time it gets in and
stabbed you later no it shouldn't be
mailed in you should vote at the booth
and
should have voter ID because when you
have voter ID that's the real deal thank
you very much we'll see